why don't you introduce our speaker mary
robinson who most of you probably
recognized was the first woman president
of ireland and then the United Nations
High Commissioner for Human Rights
between 1997 and 2002 she's an active
she was an academic a legislator and
barrister at a Senior Council of
environment and as such and in her roles
as president in High Commissioner she
has always sought to use law as an
instrument of social change and she's
argued landmark faces before the
european court of human rights as well
as in the irish sports and the european
court in luxembourg now she's based in
New York where she is leading a project
or realizing rights ethical global is a
the ethical globalization initiative
she's a family member and chair of the
Council of women world leaders if she
recently as you probably know join
Nelson Mandela defender group they call
the elders leaders devoted to conflict
resolution and the pursuit of justice in
the global village one of the things I
want you to note as we listen to Mary
Robinson is the extent to which she is
imaginatively extending the I
we're rights should be enforced and
we're right should extend so she's at
the leading edge of thinking about
migration she's the leading edge of
thing you have children she's believing
edge of thinking about the environment
in the future the conception of Rights
that she has is imagine who created and
cleaned very important and its ability
to have her here she is of course and
has a professor here at cibo and she has
time to thank you very much Lisa those
kind words if I had an opportunity to
discuss with you the introduction we
might have left out that bit about the
elders i still let me get over the shock
up against evil i think i should come to
this party and restaurant ever
but and it is a pleasure to be back
again I did have an opportunity last
year with a similar class and it's nice
for me to meet with you taking part in
the conceptual foundations of
international politics as you've heard I
do teach a seminar next term where we
link killin rights and a fairer more
ethical a globalization but that's a
small very knowledgeable room to come
together and I'm also pleased as I
saying to have the opportunity of
speaking to you and we have our dialogue
and Q&A afterwards when you're still in
a relatively early stage the first few
months and of this course which I'm told
by one of my colleagues who was the cast
of 2003 Michelle or earlier was here in
the front row that this is the sort of
rite of passage for students so it's
good that hidden rice is part of your
thinking about another day of course
itself but what you may choose to study
so I hope that you will keep human
rights clearly in mind as you go forward
and tackling the wide range of possible
concentrations which you will be able to
choose from such as international
economic policy economic and Lydia
development international finance and
banking ridge national energy policy and
so on my thesis is that human rights
relevant every one of them and that's
what we're really going to go cash and
discuss in this m-class hour and i must
say that after many years of thinking
about and working in international
affairs and politics and in my trusty as
president of ireland for seven years and
then as the UN High Commission
rice for five years and now working with
my colleagues on linking human rights
and globalization I'm well aware that
the connections particularly with macro
economics with the wider political
context and these connections are not
well understood and very often in fact
are denied so we have a task to do let
me again by focusing my comments as
afternoon on why it matters but the
ideas of human rights and law exists in
international relations first I'll
approach these topics from a theoretical
standpoint because I understand the fish
with the course that you are doing the
big theories of international relations
I'll then speak about the need for
international law and human rights for
general and then I'll draw on several
examples of how the idea rights has made
I could have made a positive difference
in very significant contexts such as the
worlds that we now know in this post
9-11 era and some of the events that are
flowed from that I plan to talk for
approximately 40 to 45 minutes and then
I'd like to open the floor for our
dialogue and conversation the course of
the arch but I enjoy much more and I
know there are mics that look around so
if you can and face your comments on
your questions as I say I know that you
are looking at the main theories of
international relations often
encapsulated in the
3.5 and realism liberalism idealism and
its options constructivism speaking
generally human rights aren't often
considered to be a tenet of realism
which most often describes human rights
as only I emphasize only a set of norms
that isn't a significant force in the
world termed and dominated by a material
force the night of states liberal theory
presents a different story it emphasizes
the gains we had from international
cooperation and from the influence of
international institutions and Maurice
loafer Dean of the Woodrow Wilson School
of Public Policy at Princeton points out
that most liberals discuss human rights
assuming the existence of a community of
liberal if you like of like-minded
liberal states but form a sphere of
peace democracy and human rights however
the behavior of liberal states towards
nations outside the circle as well as
the relations between states themselves
all outside the circle are both markedly
different the main similarity between
realism and liberalism is the state to
Center approachable spirits human rights
are most often placed under the
constructivist rubric that is as a
manifestation of the idea that world
peace and stability arise from the
consensus around shared values and norms
under this theory human rights are
pointed to by some scholars as proof of
the existence or at least the emerging
of a world culture I would think that
values and norms sound a bit soft today
like a constructor isn't really useful
in protecting
from terrorist attacks or the
instability of any given stage but it's
worth pointing out Jack's Snyder's
observation in 2004 foreign policy
magazine piece but the ideological
underpinning of much of today's
terrorism and war waging ironically
seems to be an i quote to vindicate the
constructivist Kaylee's resurgence that
is the relevance of a theory that
emphasized of the role of ideologies
identities persuasion and transnational
networks in understanding the post 9-11
world as an example of the moment as the
Bush Doctrine and indeed the sum of
atlantis fat words are both heavily
ideological again state secretary
Condoleezza Rice has also identified the
Bush Doctrine as being my quote her an
amalgam of practical realism and the
solian liberal theory I say this
illustrated the fact that rarely does a
different policy or action involving
just one theory of international
relations this is certainly the case
with human rights I'd argue that the
world came together after the Second
World War to craft a universal
declaration of human rights out of
respect for the dignity of each human
being remember article 1 all the human
beings are born free and equal in
dignity and rights and that the other
motivation was that this was the
foundation of national and international
peace the memory at that time being
fresh memory was a two world wars of a
holocaust of the dropping of nuclear
bombs on citizens in Japan and indeed
the start of the Cold War and the
massive loss of life from that war was
very fresh in people's memories and it
was a very liberal at the same time
constructivist idea
looking forward but how the world should
be it was it mean to craft something
protect against the purely realist wings
estate interaction and the result was
the beginning is the root of injured
modern international human rights law
and the architecture that has flowed
from I asked her to read some of the
chapters from a book about Eleanor
Roosevelt and the crafting of the
Universal Declaration to make it as
broad as the world of 94 th would it out
with lawyers from China from the Lebanon
from Chile from France from Canada
working under Eleanor Roosevelt who
wasn't herself a lawyer but who was of
the age and had the disposition to be
able to be very Aussie and to be able to
Buster lawyers to rank the Universal
Declaration in language that would be
understood and this was the strength of
the Universal Declaration that it looked
to the great religions in the world at
that time and drew from them that it
didn't just teach talk about rights but
also in after 29 remind people that
everyone has duties to the community but
that is good you don't reach the full
expression of your personality so that
sense of a link between asserting rights
and protecting rights including rights
of others but also having duties to the
community but what happened afterwards
and that was in mark in December the
tenth of 1948 and then afterwards the
Cold War deepened and geopolitical
forces mandated the splitting of the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
into tuned human rights covenants one of
which would deal with civil and living
rights and was very strongly endorsed by
Western countries and in particular
obviously by at the United States and
the other comment dealing with economic
social and cultural rights rights to
food and save over health and education
shelter and in this battle of ideologies
the Soviet bloc and many
country said that they would first build
their economies and try to strengthen
access to health and education before
they open up at a greater political
participation is they if they were
prepared to open up at all and so as you
read it was the international and
domestic realities and ideologies of
states that gave rise to the sharp
divide between the Soviets and their
eyes who are only too willing to endorse
economic social and cultural rights and
the United States and Western Europe who
are willing to endorse mainly primarily
only civil and political rights and
there is a reason why the United States
in particular resisted the idea that
economic and social rights were rights
as opposed to political aspirations and
this stemmed from the pre Civil Rights
amendments at United States which had an
economically and politically
disenfranchised African American
population in the south and it didn't
want that population to be legally bound
in our lay themselves we diggity bound
to that population to raising the living
standards to match those of the white
population the Soviets themselves were
living in the communist state for
similar losing rights emphasizing the
individual didn't meet the communist
goals and and were not a part of the
accepted system and so I human rights
are often conceptualized by their modern
detractors are soft they were perceived
as anything but soft in the halls of
power at the time and that they were
first presented as
your element of international law still
it's true that it remains a strategy of
many nation-states that they don't want
to be bound by international law to that
what they do is they spin human rights
as soft and it possibly is divorced from
state security in order to evade
accountability for the measures and that
they may have ratified as M treaties so
this brings me to my next point about
international law and international
human rights law in particular and one I
hope we've had some time to discuss and
that is enforceability mostly this will
tell you that international law just
simply in real terms doesn't matter
because it couldn't constrain States or
their behavior for example in waging
World War 1 or indeed World War two and
both the Caribbean packed and the league
of nations were in existence at that
time and proved to be effectual a
tendril era Syria asserted in a recent
article in the journal of international
affairs and I quote her States would
never create laws that constrain them
against their own interests nor would
they continue to conform to any law that
had once serve their interests but it
seems to do so in short low that is best
at the phenomenal and your bid for
answers in international politics at
worst reliance upon lols is naive even
dangerous in an anarchic international
system in which states uppermost
priority was to always be survival thus
the Disciplinary divide between
international law and international
relations has emerged this commenter
chandran a grocery run echoes the
sentiments of John Austin who's
questioning of the existence of
international law has been haunting the
field since the mid 19th century I did
believe that something very well-known
care in the economy
very good friend of mine professor Lulu
henken positive the best answer to
Austin's query to whether or not
international law exists almost three
decades ago my he noticed that and I
caught him almost all nations observe
almost all principles of international
law and almost all their obligations
almost all the time so in practice the
system is much more accepted then is
often realized if you allow me to
paraphrase the seminal work of New
hencken how nations obey he reminds us
that many of the core concepts
international relation today for example
sovereignty non-intervention and
immunity were developed through
interstate relations and then codified
into international law international
goal is the normative system a standard
heavy and the standard currency of
international relations much of the talk
among leaders in the world today about
democracy building is impossible but I
reference to international law and so
the question before us is not whether
international law exists but rather how
does it work how does it function and
what end or enemies to begin to answer
this question is helpful to turn to
another of the author's I signed to you
and my friend Carla Cole who is now a
team of the Indian law school but and
I'm serving as UN High Commissioner efer
time was the undersecretary for labor
and human rights and under the Clinton
administration his fundamental stance is
that international law and international
politics are not just stated centric
anymore this game is that we live in
globalized world in which my quoted in
which various actors States judges
non-government organizations
international institutions and
corporations interact to make interpret
enforce and ultimately in
paralyzed worlds of international level
international noise that's not something
that's imposed in a top-down and I
roketa fashion but a set of rules that
78 interactions among a variety of
actors within and across borders this
approach to international law diverges
significantly from traditional state
centric approaches in the multiplicity
of actors that might be engaged in the
creation and interpretation of legal
obligations so cone in effect tells us
that law is no longer the sole problems
of the stage or in other words to equate
lower on human sanctions is to a
cultural in a way that's how long are
helpful in our current context the rise
of non-state actors with our terrorist
groups such as al-qaeda or on RT
national business with economies often
larger than some states and making
efforts to address the extent of their
obligations under international law also
close this to be true it also shows us
that international relations are no
longer as I said for some problems of
the nation-state I recall the way in
which the attempt to have a land mines
Convention was stalled in the United
Nations because certain countries
including certain large country that
were in if you want to have a land mines
Convention and the hugely robust and
energized coalition of some governments
Canada paying a very strong role in this
and many NGOs a whole coalition were
mined got together and there were
various images made
Princess Diana and going to Angola and
being photographed and walking through a
minefield in fact it was an energizing
of a wife public opinion media payroll
etc and we got on land mines convention
which has saved many hundreds of
thousands of lives and led to the mines
that had been placed now being as slowly
and painfully air removed another
shortly sighs Hank III was from Nick
Holland the accepting general of the
international commission of jurists in
which he verifies that my quote large
corporations are beginning to challenge
the traditional economic and political
dominance of government and governments
are losing authority up to international
organization bodies and internally
estate functions are to a very strange
privatized account also believes Human
Rights was provided a clear binding
global rules or contact and
accountability we need as we move
forward in this age of globalization as
they are equal adequate the only
existing and internationally agreed-upon
especially of minimum conditions we all
should enjoy if we're to live in dignity
as human beings in our work so part of
the work we do in realizing rights is
working increasingly with the private
sector with business to identify the
appropriate responsibilities of
multinational corporations and how they
use a sphere of influence not displacing
the responsibility of governments
protect and promote human rights of
their citizens but because they pass a
farm and because the power of those
states is less given the privatization
of all kinds of services not just
education and health of prison services
than military roles and protections as
we see currently at wound and in Iraq
but given this more neveress structure
of actors and politics in between
it's important to ask is international
law still relevant to the operation of
nation-states I would never do that yes
it ends at the most general and
sometimes invisible level international
law regulates the world's telephone
lines so that you can and be who are
international students can call your
families that your mobile phone and
we'll work it regulates the works postal
systems so that snail mail an operation
letter is posted in Europe and arrive
here our ryan incident there's a flat
america within a reasonable amount of
time it regulates the world's oceans and
the air waits for commerce for travel
and it also needs to regulate behavior
of states and citizens as an account
again emphasizes and i quote in
international law is not a substitute
for effective national level and
policies but international standards do
help to provide common guidance to
States to harmonize rules a time a week
national regulation international rules
set minimum standards as benchmarks and
international laws need to step in we're
naturally low is absent or without a
piece in fairness to its critics I think
we must acknowledge that international
human rights law is not perfect it's an
imperfect system as Kofi Annan has said
too often international law applied
selectively and enforced arbitrary it
lacks the teeth that China Holly rolls
into a consistently effective legal
system and yet it's also young
international human rights has not been
around for that long the root of it as I
mentioned is the universal declaration
of human rights and starting the tent
this year it was mark 60th anniversary
60 believe me it's not such a great age
there is life after 60 and I'll come
back to that 60th anniversary of how we
might use it and it's interesting that
the world actually began this short
century the 21st century very well for
human rights I was serving in the United
Nations of the time but I remember being
very heartened that there was a shared
sense of the importance of the
international legal framework that had
been built up over a half a century and
that the first meeting of the General
Assembly it's a temperature thousand who
emphasized the vital role of
international human rights and rule of
law in an increasingly interdependent
world government leaders head of
nation-states express international
community's renewed commitment to the
principles of justice and international
law through the signing of the United
Nations Millennium direct declaration
during that special three day session of
the general assembly in September 2000 a
total of 273 new treaty actions took
place meaning governments are the signed
or ratified hajek positive steps in
relation to existing treaties change
their position positively and made a
commitment 187 signatures at 86
ratifications are excited sessions on
instruments such as the optional
protocol to Convention on rights the
challenge and the involvement of
children are conflict the convention on
the elimination of all forms of
discrimination against women the Rome
Statute of the International Criminal
Court and the International Convention
for the suppression of the financing of
terrorism we've been encouraged to read
the Millennium
duration it's interesting to see that
six short years ago the world framed
tackling poverty very very strong human
rights terms it was a moment of
rededication to international law and
institutions as the best hope for the
21st century and it's worth mentioning
that during the UN millennium assembly
and the largest-ever opinion poll in the
world of time was carried out the
results showed that an overwhelming
majority of people from all parts of the
world identify the need for greater
protection of human rights as their top
priority in the 21st century and and I
think it's important that people and at
that time were very much drawing the
conclusion that a world increasingly
connected by a web of technology
information transportation and commerce
must also be connected by shared values
and shared norms a world without
international law then would be to
employ the language of the realists much
more and artistic than the world in
which we currently live it would be a
world for citizens of what's less
ability to hold their governments
accountable for their rights instead of
just over the last 15 years we've seen a
number of measures and I just remind us
of them so we see the building blocks of
human rights establishment of criminal
tribunals the atrocities committed they
were wrong that in the former Yugoslavia
and the first post Nuremberg indictment
of a former head of state in the Pacific
case and I also Charles Taylor former
President of Liberia is awaiting trial
General Pinochet was held accountable
for crimes he committed against the
Chilean people under the ignoring our
principle of non-military for
international crimes committed by
someone and find still ahead of station
the adoption of the UN Security Council
resolutions that protect
children in armed conflict the
criminalization of rape is a crime
against humanity in the context of war
and ratification of the rome statute and
the creation of the International
Criminal Court and let me also show from
a draw an experience of a way in which
and I was able to observe that civil
society groups were using the
commitments governments have made to
find a process that would hold them
accountable not going into court even an
international tribunal actually working
a civil society to hold the government
accountable i remember that brazil and i
just take this as an example because
lots of countries and hadn't and didn't
compile their reports as they were as
they had undertaken to do under the
International Human Rights system and so
I salient Brazil it's more that it was a
very good way to observe how Brazilian
civil society was going to hold resile
accountable what happened was that
Brazil was in delay had not in time
submitted a report as it was bound to do
under the International Covenant on
economic Social and Cultural Rights and
a wide group of civil society from some
power of Brasilia and rio de janeiro got
together linked on the internet and drew
up an alternative report on economic
social and cultural rights for brazil
from civil society perspective then
about 11 of them came to Geneva I
Memphis high commissioner and they went
along in lunch time to the members of
the committee on economic
ultramax and the president of the
committee explained that it would not be
possible to give them a formal hearing
because that was for governments but
they were praised by the president of
the committee and the other members for
this work because that would make it
much easier to persuade Brazilian
government to compile its government
report which would allow the civil
society to differ in some respects and
maybe put in an alternative reporter and
a parallel report and to that government
report and as it happened Timoth later I
was making an efficient business I
Commissioner to Brazil so I land and
with the heavy report of the society
groups under my arm and in front of the
media I say i'm going to ask bazillion
government where is the government's
report and this became quite an issue
and civil society that great boost of
attention to their alternative report
and then the then minister for human
rights since minister state for human
rights and said well we agreed that we
shouldn't be in today we will now and
give it priority and produce a
government report and it's interesting
that the den minister was the current
Special Rapporteur on human rights who
is visiting Myanmar on behalf of the
United Nations distinguished human
rights advocate a publicity of panera
and he was kept out with me in our mar
for three years but yesterday he was
getting back in from first time is going
to try to and address the question of
how many are imprisoned how many were
killed during the recent disturbances
here the recent conflict there is effort
but it was he who made a commitment and
we have a discussion but it wasn't
sufficient for the government
politically to bring in its report but
it should engage with these women's
groups poverty groups and those who are
fighting the landless room to zephyr in
brazil and work together and if there
was difference the civil society groups
could put in a parallel report and
several months later an assertive narrow
and told me that this was a real bridge
that was created between his ministry
and
government ministers and these civil
society groups so it was a process that
held to accountability in a more
political way and was determined that
there had to be accountability but it
wasn't a matter of going to court in a
more traditional way obviously they
can't have a complete discussion about
the centrality of human rights and
international role in international
relations for that a million the impact
of the terror attacks in this country of
what we love September the 11 2001 which
obviously shook the United States and
the world since that day the commitments
that i mentioned that were made by
nation states start with you century
have I believe being overshadowed by the
threats of terrorism by fears and
uncertainties about the future and I
questions about the viability of a
network of open societies joined by
norms and values the whole approach of
characterizing response as a war on
terrorism and has made the inside lining
of human rights and indeed the dipping
of standards on issues like torture and
seem more acceptable I say scene because
the price is extremely high doesn't work
and run the lines and extremely
important standards and I spent the last
18 months as part of a team called the
eminent jurist panel of the
international commission of jurists
having hearings in about 20 countries
including the United States and
and last year and on the fifth
anniversary of 911 we are here in
Washington are also be in Moscow my
colleagues have been in different parts
of the world in Africa and Asia in
united kingdom belfast and so on and he
issued press releases and the are
we found but really what we're trying to
do is assess the trends assess how
serious aftermath has been and they
knock on effect of standards being
dipped and we will be reporting on that
and early in the year and obviously the
fact that united states and has not
fully upheld international standards
such as a convention against torture
that neva conventions and has had a
negative impact because in some
countries have tried to explain that
there is now that the standards have
changed and it's been important to
assert the standards have not changed
even if they are not in a pedal in the
way that they should the appellant and
the final point I want to make about and
international human rights in practice
is to recognize that if a more secure
and peaceful world is the end goal
international law and the primary goal
of theories international relations then
we must remember that 911 didn't in fact
change much in the lives of most people
on the planet human insecurity was
already a daily biology for 911 for the
hundreds of millions who live in
absolute poverty or in zones of conflict
and it remained so for these people in
security isn't equated with where
terrorists may strike but instead with
where tomorrow's only Neil may come from
or how a decent job can be found in when
you've got eighty percent
employment as will provide enough income
to buy life-saving medicines maybe for a
dying child for women gender is itself a
risk factor threatening their security
the secret violence of hustle lives the
private impressions of lack of property
inheritance rights they night flower
decorations that goes with a nice
cooling and the structural album of
political exclusion in other words the
comprehensive insecurity of the powers
and this is I think where we have a
challenge that we may want to discuss a
little bitch the millennium declaration
was a commitment framed in human rights
terms to tackle these devised a positive
and then the sideline of human rights
after terror attacks on 911 also helped
to open up an ideological divide and we
see this reflected in many parts of the
world the Divine's and on religious
grounds the ideological divides and the
sense of an opening and rift between
countries and and I come back then and
to conclude my remarks and open up our
discussion to the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights when I was serving as UN
High Commission i started in September
1997 and found it was a small unit in
the office in Geneva working on the 50th
anniversary of the Universal Declaration
and I asked them you know how are you
worried about that holy plan the 50th
anniversary they said the first thing
we've done was look at how they planned
the 40th anniversary and i discovered
that Peter Gabriel had old series and
concerts about human rights of other
things that happened for the 40th
anniversary and then we planned do it on
a wider scale and there were lots of
invitations to speak and we tried to
raise certain issues and put more
emphasis actually economical surgery
lights during that 50th anniversary year
but the truth is with many think about
it there is no similar comparison
between now as we are about to mark the
60th anniversary and how the 50th
anniversary of his mind it's not worth
looking back it's as if it was a
completely different world and we can be
conscious of one very negative problem
that I've talked about the impact of the
attacks of 911 focus on security on war
on terrorism and the other mining
standards that have been held very
firmly up to them and vivid some torture
and holding people indefinitely on time
obey etc but is also a very positive and
potential and that is the huge rise in
communications in our world of 2007
going into the 16th anniversary year can
communicate like never before and the
elders this body that I somehow have and
been told i'm eligible for and i decided
to have a kind of gentle training a
public hope would be a very wide leak a
little to the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights and if you leadership there
are many many language versions on the
office of High Commission on Human
Rights I know that because what I was
been serving as High Commissioner I got
the guinness book of records for the
most translated document in the world in
short it's 30 articles and the General
Assembly that was adopted in Paris said
that they called upon every individual
and every organ on society bearing this
declaration constantly in mind by
teaching and education child protection
of the rights of
freedom's contained therein so it wasn't
primarily a matter of only for
governments it was a little like Howard
coal seams the interactions
international law the many actors who
must take part individuals students and
those who are teaching here in Columbia
and that's where the private sector and
I was talking this morning and the
leader of a very large company about
potential for his company to post on the
website too and make sure that every
employee is aware of the Universal
Declaration but also to live in supply
chain and see whether physics for
explosion conditions work and trying to
leave her and forced labor any kind to
see whether the environmental and
concerns will be addressed and so on and
and if we think about it the world that
I described in 1948 was very fearful and
anxious about our world today in similar
terms we have many of the same problems
in the nuclear proliferation not only
very much and as a matter of concern but
also potentially linked to a dirty bomb
problem but in the new form of potential
terrorism and fear we have the idea of a
device that I mentioned and we have the
challenges and potential catastrophic
impact of climate change and in that
sense if we're to address these
challenges we need those common values
the world needs to be reminded that Edna
government in the world every government
accepts the University
Human Rights implementation and
enforcement or not but it's not disputed
and they are the rights of the
birthright individuals so I think we can
see human rights as being a huge
potential exercising soft heart if we
can use the universal declaration three
central human rights for they were
beginning of this century maybe this
will have huge impacts on how we address
climate change how we address Millennium
Development Goals how we move forward so
in that sense I think both international
human rights and international law
generally have a huge arm to influence
in our world and that's really what I'd
like to discuss with you now so the
floor is open to whoever wants to take
the challenge thank you